[Applause]
well first of all thank you
for your attention there's nothing quite
like being in a room full of people like
this
where all of you are giving your
attention to
me it's uh it's a powerful feeling
to get attention i'm an actor
so uh i'm a bit of an expert on uh well
nothing
really um but i do know what it feels
like to get
attention i've been lucky in my life to
get a lot more than my fair share of
attention
and uh i'm grateful for that because
like i said it's a powerful
feeling but there's another powerful
feeling
that i've also been lucky to experience
a lot as an actor
and it's funny it's sort of the opposite
feeling because it doesn't come from
getting attention comes from paying
attention
when i'm acting i get so focused
that i'm only paying attention to one
thing
like when i'm on set and we're about to
shoot and the first ad calls out rolling
and then i hear speed marker set and
then the director
calls action i've heard that sequence so
many times like
it's become this pavlovian magic spell
for me rolling
speed marker set and action something
happens to me i can't even help it my
attention
narrows and everything else in the world
anything else that might be
bothering me or my grab my attention
it all goes away and and i just
there and
that feeling that is what i love
that to me is creativity and and that's
the biggest reason i'm so grateful that
i get to be an actor
so there's these two powerful feelings
there's getting attention and paying
attention
of course in the last decade or so new
technology has allowed more and more
people to have this
powerful feeling of getting attention
for any kind of creative expression not
just acting could be
writing or photography or drawing or
music everything the
channels of distribution have been
democratized
and that's a good thing
but i do think there's an unintended
consequence for
anybody on the planet with an urge to be
creative
myself included because i'm not immune
to this
i think that our creativity
is becoming more and more of a means to
an end
and that end is to get attention
and so i feel compelled to speak up
because in my experience
the more i go after that powerful
feeling of paying attention
the happier i am but the more i go after
the powerful feeling of getting
attention
the unhappier i am and
so this is something that goes way back
for me uh
i think the first time i can remember uh
using my acting to get
attention i was eight years old at
summer camp
and i've been going on auditions for
about a year by then and i've been lucky
to
get some small parts and tv shows and
commercials
and i bragged about it a lot
that summer at camp and uh at first it
worked
the other kids gave me a bunch of extra
attention because
i had been on family ties that's a
picture of me on family ties right
then the tide turned i think i took it
too far with the bragging
and and then the other kids started to
make fun of me
i remember there was this and there's
this one girl i had a crush on
rocky her name was rachel she went by
rocky
and uh she was beautiful and she could
sing and i was smitten with her and i
was standing there
bragging and she turned to me and she
called me a show-off
which i 100 deserved but you know it's
still
it really hurt and ever since that
summer
i've had a certain hesitance to seek
attention
from my acting and sometimes you know
people would ask me they'd be like well
wait a minute if you don't like the
attention
then why are you an actor and i'd be
like because that's not what acting's
about man it's about the art
and they'd be like okay okay dude
and then twitter came out and i got
totally hooked on it just like everybody
else which made me into a complete
hypocrite because at that point i was
absolutely using my acting
to get attention i mean what did i think
i was just getting
all these followers because of my
brilliant tweets
i actually did think that i was like you
know they don't just like because they
saw me in batman they like what i have
to say i've got away with words
then in no time at all it started having
an impact on my dearly beloved creative
process
it still does i try not to let it but
you know
i'll be sitting there like reading a
script
and instead of thinking okay how can i
personally identify with this character
or
how is the audience going to relate to
this story i'm like
what are people going to say about this
movie on twitter and what will i say
back that'll be good and snarky enough
to get a lot of retweets but not too
harsh because people love to get
offended and i don't want to get
canceled these are the thoughts that
enter my mind while i'm like
supposed to be reading a script trying
to you know be an artist
and i'm not here to tell you that
technology is the enemy of creativity
i don't think that i think tech is just
a tool it has a potential
to foster unprecedented human creativity
like i even started an online
community called hit record where people
all over the world collaborate on all
kinds of creative projects so
i don't think that social media or
smartphones or
any technology is problematic in and of
itself
but if we're going to talk about the
perils of creativity
becoming a means to get attention then
we have to talk about the
attention-driven business model
of today's big social media companies
right okay
so this will be familiar territory for
some of you but it's a really relevant
question here
how does a social media platform like
for example instagram
make money it's not selling a photo
sharing service
that part's free so what is it selling
it's selling attention
it's selling the attention of its users
to advertisers and there's a lot of
discussion right now about how much
attention we're all giving
to things like instagram but my question
is how is instagram
getting so much attention we get it for
them
anytime somebody posts on instagram they
get a certain amount of attention
from their followers whether they have a
few followers or a few million followers
and
the more attention you're able to get
the more attention instagram is able to
sell
so it's an instagram's interest for you
to get as much attention as possible
and so it trains you to want that
attention to crave it to
feel stressed out when you're not
getting enough of it
instagram gets its users addicted
to the powerful feeling of getting
attention
and i know we all joke like oh my god
i'm so addicted to my phone but this is
a real
addiction there's a whole science to it
um if you're curious
i recommend the work of jaren lanier
tristan harris
near ayo but here's what i can tell you
being addicted to getting attention it's
just like being addicted to anything
else
it's never enough you start out and
you're thinking
well if only i had a thousand followers
that would feel
amazing but then you're like well once i
get to ten thousand followers and that
once i get to
a hundred once i get to a million
followers then i'll feel
amazing so i have
4.2 million followers on twitter it's
never made me feel amazing
i'm not going to tell you how many i
have on instagram because i feel
genuine shame about how low the number
is because i joined instagram
after batman came out
and i search other actors and i see that
their number is higher than mine and it
makes me feel
terrible about myself because the
follower count
makes everybody feel terrible about
themselves that feeling
of inadequacy is what drives you to post
so you can get more attention and that
attention that you get is what these
companies sell
that's how they make their money
so there is no amount of attention you
can get
where you feel like you've arrived and
you're like ah
i'm good now and of course there are a
lot of actors you know who are a lot
more famous than i am
have more followers than i do but i bet
you they would tell you the same thing
if your creativity is driven by a desire
to get attention
you're never gonna be creatively
fulfilled
but i do have some good news
there's this other powerful feeling
something else you can do with your
attention besides letting a giant tech
company control it and sell it
this is that feeling i was talking about
why i love acting so much it's being
able to
pay attention to just one thing
turns out there's actually some science
behind this too uh
psychologists and neuroscientists they
study a phenomenon they call flow
which is this thing that happens in the
human brain when someone pays attention
to just one thing
like something creative and manages not
to get distracted by
anything else and some say the more
regularly you do this
the happier you'll be now i'm not a
psychologist or a neuroscientist
but i can tell you for me that is very
true
it's not always easy it's hard to really
pay attention like this takes practice
everybody does it their own way but if
there's one thing i can share
that i think helps me focus and and
really pay attention is this
i try not to see other creative people
as my competitors i try to find
collaborators
like if i'm acting in a scene if i start
seeing the other actors as my
competitors and i'm like oh my god
they're going to get more attention than
i am people are going to be talking
about their performance more than my
performance like
i've lost my focus and by the way i'm
probably going to suck and that's him
but when i see the other actors as
collaborators
then it becomes almost easy to
focus because i'm just paying attention
to them
i don't have to think about what i'm
doing i just i react to what they're
doing
they react to what i'm doing and we can
kind of keep each other in it together
but i don't want you to think there's
only actors on a set that can
collaborate in this way i could be
whatever kind of creative situation it
could be professional
could be just for fun i could be
collaborating with people i'm not even
in the same
room with in fact some of my favorite
things i've ever made i made with people
that
i never physically met and by the way
this
to me is the beauty of the internet if
we could just stop
competing for attention then the
internet becomes a great place to find
collaborators
and once i'm collaborating with other
people
whether they're on set or online
wherever
that makes it so much easier for me to
find that
flow because we're all just paying
attention to the one
thing that we're making together and i
feel like i'm
part of something larger than myself and
we all sort of
shield each other from anything else
that might otherwise grab
our attention and we can all just be
there at least that's
what works for me sometimes
sometimes it doesn't always work
sometimes i still totally get wrapped up
in
in that addictive cycle of wanting to
get attention i mean like
even right now can i honestly say
there's not some part of me here who's
like
hey everybody look at me i'm giving a
ted talk
there is there's you know some part
but i can also i can honestly say that
this whole creative process of writing
and
giving this talk it's been a huge
opportunity for me to focus
and really pay attention to something i
care a lot about
so regardless of how much attention i do
or don't get
as a result i'm happy i did it
and i'm grateful to all of you
for letting me so thank you that's it
you can
give your attention to someone else now
thanks again